[Music]
i thought that was really creative
and totally possible my name is d'andra
leslie pilecki
i have a phd in physics and i started
off my life as a condensed matter
physicist working in nanomedicine
along the way i ended up writing a book
called the physics of nascar so today
i'm going to use that knowledge to talk
to you about some clips from fast and
[Music]
curious
this is one is a little difficult to
analyze because you're not quite
sure how long they're falling can be
anywhere from 11 seconds to maybe 15
seconds
that's a really long time to fall i
calculated out
what dom's terminal velocity would be
and that's the biggest velocity you can
fall given that drag
gets bigger as the speed goes up and he
almost approaches it
after 11 seconds dom would be going 124
miles per hour
when he hit the water he would have
fallen about
1775 feet at that point
now 124 miles per hour into water
maybe that's survivable holds the record
for the highest jump
that was from 193 feet he hit the water
at 76 miles an hour
he broke his right clavicle and
dislocated his pelvis the golden gate
bridge
is about 245 feet people hit the water
at 86 miles an hour
only five percent of the people who
jumped survived so the probability of
them surviving
is pretty small they built a launcher
and took this beautiful 1966
corvette and actually launched it on the
side of the cliff and then they had
stuntmen who did it separately from the
car because
getting hit by a car mid-air would be
worse than actually hitting the water
and so they had the stuntman to do it
but the stuntmen were on cables
then they came back did it on a green
screen with the actual actors
who were you know maybe eight feet above
the ground this one
i think i would have to give a score of
two because
there's absolutely no way they could
have survived to jump that long
so this is a 1969 camaro it's got a mass
of about 3 500 pounds
so they're hitting 90 so you know the
boat's going at least 90 miles an hour
one of the things that you notice is
that when the car and the boat are both
speeding along they're parallel to each
other
now how they all of a sudden get behind
the boat i'm not actually
sure how that happens but let's assume
they can do that when they take off
they're going at approximately
45 degree angle off this ramp
and they're going 120 miles an hour so
not all of the speed
is taking them in the horizontal
direction so if you take cosine of 45
they're only now going about 78 miles
per hour toward the boat
now that's a problem because the boat
and the car
look like they were going the same speed
and the problem is if the boat's going
100 miles per hour
it'll be 1200 feet from the shore the
problem is the car can only go 945 feet
in the time it's in the air
there's actually no way that the car
could make it onto the boat
let's pretend the boat is only going 78
miles an hour because if they are
it's totally possible it is going fast
enough and it makes up all the distance
between
it and the boat so if you include drag
they're going to lose some
of their speed due to air resistance
they're still going to hit that boat at
around 105 miles per hour
the kinetic energy of the car and the
guys in the car at that point
is equal to about a fifth of a pound of
tnt
some of that goes into wrecking the boat
and wrecking the car but
not all of it which means some of it is
going to go into the guys and
they're going to have a whole lot worse
than a broken arm
i think i'd give it probably a 7 out of
10 because it's possible
it could happen they had to modify this
tank so it could go 60 miles an hour
because they normally only go 30 miles
an hour
dom will assume his car was going 60
miles an hour so when he left it he was
going 60 miles an hour
so you can look at conservation momentum
and figure out that
by the time they hit and continued on
they were probably going around
40 miles an hour so a little bit of
change in speed
but the problem is when you get the car
going 40 miles an hour
and she is about 120 pounds he's about
225 so you're talking about
340 or so pounds you're gonna be hitting
it with an acceleration of almost 100 g
they have no protective gear so you know
race car drivers routinely survive picks
of 100g
they're got a big car around them and
maybe it's possible that dom
could launch himself at just the right
angle to intercept light
and then maybe it's possible that that
path took him onto
the second bridge instead of over the
first one
and maybe it's possible that there
happened to be a car at the point where
they were landing
maybe it's possible to survive hitting
the car together
each one of those things might have
happened but all four of them together
is just
too much of a coincidence once you're in
the air you cannot steer
so if you misjudge in any way you're
gonna miss her now
when you watch baseball players they
develop this very intuitive ability to
know
the arc of a ball and after all it's
just a parabolic motion
maybe just don understands physics so
well that he knew exactly where to
launch himself and if you talk to race
car driver they will be
able to understand centrifugal
acceleration and explain it to you again
no equations but they get this intuitive
understanding for it
so it's just possible maybe dom has
rescued enough people who were flying
through the air that he understands how
to do it
[Music]
hollywood has its own physics one of the
rules is they have
time dilation which is that when
something really exciting is happening
it can take as long as you want it to
take it's slowing down
let's say 120 miles an hour and i picked
that number
only because that'll tell you at 120
miles an hour
the car is going two miles every minute
so for every minute of that cliff you're
traveling two miles
the longest airport runway in the world
is 3.4 miles
which means that they were on that
runway this cliff would take 1.7 minutes
and it doesn't it takes a lot it takes
like 11 or 12 minutes which would result
in
just this unfathomably long runway okay
so don is driving a 2012
dodge charger and let's pretend that
this is a super reinforced version of a
dodge cargo
he doesn't have a lot of time to get up
speed because he's only got the inside
of the plane and as you saw from the
fight that was going on there's not a
lot of room i think i have to give a one
just because here they've stretched my
ability to
ignore reality just a little further
than i'm capable of doing
try to figure out how much that vault
weighs according to the storyline
so we're gonna assume it's a five ton
vault that's about ten thousand pounds
there's a hundred million dollars in one
hundred dollar bills
that's going to give us another twenty
two hundred pounds
dom is 225 pounds and the car
is 4180 pounds that gives us a total
weight
of 16 605 pounds
that his car has to accelerate if you've
ever tried to
move something heavy like a refrigerator
or a bookcase
you push on it and it doesn't move and
you push harder it doesn't move
you push harder and finally it moves
that moment when it moves
you've just overcome the static
frictional force the static frictional
force is higher
than the kinetic frictional force and
what that means in real people talk
is that once you get something moving
it's much easier to keep it moving
so the question is is it possible for
this 210
charger srt to overcome the friction
needed to
move so we're going to calculate how
long it would take him to accelerate up
to 50 miles an hour
we've got the 425 horsepower car
six accelerating 16 five pounds and it
turns out that would take about five
point eight six seconds
which is a little longer than it took
him to actually do it in the movie
so the fact that he got the car
accelerating that fast
that definitely couldn't happen in real
life but that's without friction so once
you put friction in
what you find you calculate is that the
coefficient of friction
between like steel and asphalt
is pretty high and you probably could
not even with the nitrous oxide boost
get the vault moving so once you got it
moving you could keep it moving
what the folks have said who did this
stunt they found the same thing they
learned about about static friction the
hard way
and they actually put a slippery
material on the bottom of the ball to
get it moving
but one of the problems with that is
when you make something easier to start
moving
you also make it easier to stop moving
and my understanding is they were very
surprised when they thought it would
come to a stop and it took a lot longer
to stop than we thought it would
the other thing is the question of you
have this fairly small mass of the car
and dom that's about 2 000 pounds and
the mass of the ball
which is about 15 000 times so you've
got something that's
seven times bigger than something else
now
think about when they're coming down and
then dom starts
stops and he lets the vault sort of
swing around the vault is
you know sometimes heavier than dom in
his car and i just don't buy
that he has enough traction to swing the
ball without the ball
pulling his car along making these
stunts work
in real life with practical effects and
not cgi
they built something like seven or eight
different vaults with different weights
so that they could do all the different
parts of the bulb and in fact in some
points
they actually had a little semi-cab
inside the ball
and the vault was driving around by
itself so i would give this stunt a 5.
[Music]
i mean we've all tried to go you know up
down escalator right
that's all he's doing there
this whole stunt relies on the person
being able to run
faster than the bus is falling when they
feel this the some person did actually
run
up the bus as it was falling i had some
real questions because
it's not like you're pushing off
something solid you're pushing off
something that's moving in the other
direction
it's spun around to be in exactly the
right position for him to grab the bar
when he's holding the bar and she stops
suddenly you get this really great
example of newton's law of motion where
an object in motion will keep moving
because she stops the car and he keeps
going flying around i would give this
one
a 10 for running up the bus i thought
that was really creative
and totally possible
again you see a lot of tight shots so it
does make it hard to see what's going on
necessarily
this is a lycan hyper car and it's got
780 horsepower
as far as 3.4 million dollars there's
only seven of them in the world
sometimes i think they put it in slow
motion just so people like me
can't do the detailed calculations and
mess with them how fast you have to be
going
so that you can span the distance
between the buildings
so if we assume that distance is 150
feet
you're going to fall a little bit so
anytime something comes off
horizontally it's going to go down a
little bit and you can actually see it
in there
that it probably falls about two stories
which is roughly
20 feet and so the question is how fast
you have to be going
to fall two stories in 150 feet of
horizontal distance
if you're gonna fall two floors it would
take just a little more than a second
and you need to be going 137 miles per
hour
if you fall four floors it'd be about
1.6 seconds
you have to be going only 95 miles per
hour now this car has a top speed of 245
miles per hour
top speed is no problem what is a
problem however is how long it takes you
to get to top speed
so the car goes 0 to 60 miles an hour in
2.8 seconds in order to do that it needs
123 feet with the same constant
acceleration
those look like pretty small spaces
because he was doing an awful lot of
turning as he was going around
that's only 60 miles an hour if you
wanted to get to 125 miles an hour
according to the specs that would take
you 9.4 seconds
you would need 861 feet to reach that
speed
and i don't see how you do that in that
tiny little tower
the other problem is that when they're
just driving around
they must be pulling tremendous g-forces
because they're driving these tiny
little circles i tried to look up the
coefficient of friction
between tires and marble but it turns
out that it's very hard to find because
most people do not drive cars
in their apartment buildings so i
couldn't find that but even so
and you know i questioned and going at
high speed on marble whether you can
even keep traction going around like
that
you know again you've got another
example of there's a bunch of things
that could happen
and if you put them all together you
might not buy it
even the very strong reinforced glass
they would use on a skyscraper like this
is not going to stand up to a car that's
3 000
pounds traveling at 120 130 miles per
hour
the kinetic energy of the car is just
too high
is he not wearing a seat belt the whole
time
you guys love the look after after he
does these things i mean
he just sort of looks like oh i
understand this charger was especially
modified so it could drive on ice
obviously the ice here is going to be
pretty thick
but if you've got that much heat it's
going to melt the ice and that's going
to make it much harder to get traction
the physics of
how the car would move after he hit it
that was pretty accurate i was
pretty impressed by that one of the
things that happens that people don't
appreciate
is when a car is on fire the fire
quickly depletes all the oxygen
and it's using it out but if you're in a
car you get very very warm
you get disoriented there's smoke you
can't see what you're doing and so i
think
when something's on fire him coming out
of this amount of fire that's got some
issues with the realism too
i don't see any reason why this couldn't
happen so i this one i would have given
10 i think this one's pretty plausible
so if you look up a fuel tanker that
holds
oh i don't know maybe 7 000 gallons of
gasoline
the density of gasoline is 6.06
pounds per gallon about 42 000
pounds coming toward them now if it were
something doing
you know moving regularly or something
bouncing that'd be fine because you
could gauge it it's like a jump rope
where you know it's coming around you
know to jump
but the problem with this is if you look
how it's rolling it's rolling in this
direction and it's rolling
forward so there's no way you can
predict exactly
how it's going to roll if the tanker is
42
000 pounds in the car is 4 000 pounds
it's gonna squish the car
so my first car was a 1988 buick saber
which is about the same size as the 1987
european national that you see the
chances of it rolling over the tanker
pretty darn slow when the tanker starts
rolling it's got a certain amount of
kinetic energy
but every time it hits something like
the wall of canyon or the ground it's
going to lose some of that kinetic
energy
and that means it's not going to bounce
as high so actually the longer he waves
the harder it is going to be for him to
get his car
under that tanker so i'll give that one
[Music]
this is a nissan 350z i believe the
person inside the car
is actually using a combination of the
steering wheel
clutch and brakes to make the car go
around the turn
and it turns out it's actually easier to
drift around a turn
than it is to drift in a straight
direction i believe that this guy could
probably do that but i'd like to know
how many takes it took but you can drift
for as long as your tires will hold out
it's a problem because you want to have
equal traction on
all four wheels and that means you need
the same amount of weight
in drifting what you want is you want
the rear end of the car to be able to
slide back and forth
you're not actually driving where the
tires are rolling you're actually
sliding those tires
and so it's a totally different
phenomenon at some point
um you're going to do enough damage to
them that they're probably going to pop
a good driver
can definitely do that now if they would
have shown the other guy
who's just learning doing that i would
have given it a zero
this is a perfect example of a static
equilibrium so as long as all the cars
are pulling with the same force
dom can't go anywhere and what that
means is imagine it's just dom and two
cars one pulling left
one pulling right those two cars are
pulling with equal force
dom can't do anything the problem you
have is the traction between the tires
and the ground is what is our limiting
factor here
and they're talking about his car having
2 000 horsepower
3000 horsepower 5 000 horsepower i don't
know if it has that much
all it has to have is enough horsepower
to get a little bit of slack
what he's doing is all he has to do is
get enough slack that he can move
forward
but what i'm not understanding here is
what's happening to the forces on him
from behind
and of course once he gets one of them
then you've got unbalanced force
the only reason this works is because
the net sum of all the forces on this
car
is going to be zero and once he breaks
free of one
all hell breaks loose this only works if
the people on the other side
aren't doing their job right we have a
theory that one of the people in the
other cars
momentarily lost concentration and that
must be how he got out of it
because that's all we could figure out
how to make it happen and the problem
the problem giving something like this a
grade
is that you don't get to see all of it
because you're seeing the insides of
each of the cars
and you're not seeing the overhead view
it's really hard to see how that
[Music]
happened
[Music]
the doctor has to have taken that into
account because the purpose of the cast
is to immobilize the arm
and you have to take into account the
fact that you can flex his arm so
could flexing the arm break the plaster
of paris um i bet it could
why wouldn't you assume i mean maybe
that's why he's always wearing
sleeveless clothing well you know it's
hard to extrapolate because
i know i couldn't do that so you watch
some of those things
and you go yeah he might be able to do
that they aren't exactly 100 true to
life
i love these movies i think they're fun
to watch and i think it's really great
to watch something knowing the guys are
going to win